hi there steve kaufman here uh today i
want to talk about a subject that comes
up quite often
and it's about whether one can learn two
languages at the same time and i'm going
to talk a bit about my experience
before i get into that though i want to
make a confession
i am not very with it when it comes to
technology uh my son mark gets annoyed
when i have to ask him for the most
simple things
uh
but
nevertheless i use technology a lot
and it certainly enriched my experience
as a language learner
but i tried to record in fact i did
record a discussion
uh with richard simcott uh in english
and in french i think they're quite
interesting uh when i listen to them on
my desktop i can hear both voices when i
uploaded the recording to youtube
people can only hear richard and they're
left trying to lip read what i have to
say now it's more important to listen to
richard but
uh still i'm gonna try to figure out and
if anybody has any advice on how to get
my voice on there
uh i would greatly appreciate it just
before i get on to the subject of
of two languages at once talking about
technology
you know i didn't know for example that
you could use this little stylus with my
ipad or with my iphone for that matter
you know
ipad which i use i use link on my ipad
it is a lot easier with a stylus i
hardly recommend
anyone who's not aware of it who might
be as much of a
a retrograde as i am get a stylus there
three eight ten dollars i see different
prices on the internet i bought mine for
ten dollars i'm gonna get another one
for my wife they're great
uh speaking of technology i'm going to
be using a little
uh microphone like this called a
snowflake which replaces my snowball and
no real reason except that
i got one for yarda in the czech
republic and i'm going to use it when i
go traveling
and i'm just curious to see if any of
you notice any difference in the sound
quality
now getting back to
uh oh one other thing too
uh well no let's get into the subject of
two languages i've always taken the
position that i need to concentrate on
one language
at one time and therefore i have avoided
learning two languages at the same time
now recently i have been concentrating
my efforts on check
and i've kind of been allowing my
russian to languish
uh so i've noticed that my russian has
become a little bit rusty uh i started
up uh with some conversations in fact i
have had some conversations
uh but i noticed that it's slipping a
bit i think some of my tutors might have
noticed that it's slipping i might have
a conversation a week or two
now
uh
and of course with my check i'm making
progress but while i have had
discussions in czech
i do very poorly in these discussions in
fact at link i can see how many
discussions i've had in each i've had
about 250 in russian over a i think a
three or three year period and i've had
25 in check
now
what i decided to do is i decided that
this past week i would only work on
russian
and leave the check aside
and i've decided to try to alternate one
week of russian with one week of check
and the reason i'm doing that is this
uh i always say in language learning
there are the three key elements
motivation the time with the language
and then developing the ability to
notice those are the key three things
now i have lots of motivation no
shortage
time is a problem trying to find the
time to learn languages because i like
doing other things i like you know
sports i like
i have my company to to at least be
involved with i don't really run it on a
day-to-day basis i mean there's lots of
things to do there's just
not enough time
i
kind of feel that it's possible that you
can achieve more because i do want to
improve my russian
uh maybe if you alternate and and here's
why i think it could be possible and
we'll find out what happens
uh as
this book says the one that i recommend
that i mentioned quite frequently is is
lehnen
by manfred spitzer
you know
unfortunately
in other words
uh brain research and
the school of life and but he talks
about lifelong learning but one of his
and it's an excellent book and talks
about the brain and learning and one of
his many gems in there
is the fact that the brain requires
repetition and novelty
uh i think it's perhaps a bit like you
know um
exercise if you always do the same
exercise if you always run the same
distance if you always lift the same
weights after a while the brain gets you
or the muscles get used to it so in
order to introduce and i have in terms
of my own learning let's say i've
checked i do alternate between easy
material and difficult material
but i think this is going to be
interesting to try to alternate one week
of each uh one thing i did find
was that
leaving my russian of course my russian
became a little bit rusty when it came
to using it it didn't affect my ability
to read it or to understand it if i
downloaded some interviews from
ecommerce i had no trouble understanding
it
but my ability to to to marshall up my
words and to speak correctly seemed to
decline
one week on russian i'm ahead of where i
was
so that my period of time with the check
has improved my russian
why is that i think because
when you i haven't had the russian i go
back to the russian i'm learning it
again
i don't know it just seems to be that
this novelty factor stimulates the brain
the other thing that i have been doing
and i mentioned it in a previous video
in order again to to develop my
attentiveness
when it comes to cases
and and i i'm not at all prevented from
understanding the russian that i read
but i make mistakes when i speak i use
the cases incorrectly
uh i don't know what percentage i hit
correctly is it 50 60 70 i don't know
it comes from a lack of attentiveness in
my mind if i can train the brain better
even while reading i think that the
brain will get more used to these
cases
and and i hope i said cases not tense as
cases
and therefore we'll produce them better
because it'll have a better sense it'll
be more alert to more attentive to the
overall picture of cases so in reading
my russian i don't have the book handy
but i'm reading the biography of
alexander ii and i am writing down a
number
so one for the uh nominative and these
are mind numbers other people have
different
numbering systems but this is the one
that makes sense to me one for the
nominative two for the accusative three
for the genitive
uh four for the dative five for the
instrumental and 6 for the prepositional
case so i just write these down
i feel that that has really improved my
ability to speak russian i've had a
number of russian conversations this
past week and i feel that i've done
better than in the past
so i'm going to alternate however
the other thing that i'm going to do is
i'm only going to read and listen to
check i'm not going to speak check for
for the next long while so that in the
week that i'm on check i just listen to
read because
honestly i'm tired of struggling with uh
these uh conversations with our tutors
i may do the odd one maybe once a week
but no more than that whereas i'll do
four or five a week in russian and the
reason is
that i know from my reading i know that
my check reading is improving
a lot and i i read so much more
comfortably now than before
and i know that i can accumulate through
link through all the material that i've
uploaded that i'm listening to and
reading i can accumulate
this vocabulary and this familiarity
with the language so i'm quite happy to
wait another few months before again
engaging in in conversation and i feel
that if i try to speak both russian and
czech i'm going to confuse them and it's
going to be bad for my czech and bad for
my russian so for the next few months at
least that's the plan we'll see what
happens i'm going to sort of listen and
read off and on czech and russian
but i'm going to stay with russian as
the main language that i speak so in the
week that i'm strong on russian i'll
probably have five or six or seven
conversations and when it's an uh a
check week i might have one or two just
to maintain the russian so that's going
to be the plan the strategy vis-a-vis
learning two languages at the same time
i should explain in that regard
that
uh
you know
one of the things that that i've enjoyed
in the last few uh days i've had
conversations with luca i had a
conversation with richard simcott these
are two of the sort of better known
polyglots on the internet
and where we agree is obviously that you
need passion you need motivation for the
language
uh but that we also need to do the
things that we enjoy doing everyone
agrees with this and richard has certain
things that he likes doing luca has
things that he likes doing
and i do the things that i like doing
and each one of you or every learner has
to decide what they like doing so they
can listen to me they can listen to
richard luca benny whoever and they have
to decide what they best like doing
because that's probably going to work
best for them so in my case
i'm not that interested in speaking
early
to me
language learning is not a race
it's not the first guy off the blocks
it's not a hundred yard dash to see who
can say things and my own view again
this is me i think that in schools where
we try to get people to produce the
language correctly
early
uh
personally i'm against that i think it's
it's asking us to perform
uh before we're ready
uh and we don't need to perform to me
language learning is a long walk
a long journey
uh in fact getting to where you can say
a few things is quite easy
getting to where you are comfortable
with a wide variety of content where you
can read and listen to many things takes
a long long time because it requires a
lot of words if i don't understand
something it's because i don't have the
words it's not the grammar that prevents
me from understanding and if i
understand well i will be able to speak
if i can speak and i don't understand i
can get myself into trouble so that's me
okay uh i know that richard for example
is taking a course in turkish which he
really enjoys and he finds that it
provides him with additional stimulus
motivation friendship uh contact with
the culture and so forth uh luca for
example has a technique which he
describes as bilingualism where he likes
to deal with with translated texts and
he likes to translate uh
into from the new language into his
language from his language back into the
new language i don't have the discipline
to do that so i don't do it but that's
not to say that either one of those
approaches are bad i am sure they're
very effective you have only to see the
results
with richard and luca to see that both
those approaches work very well they
work very well because
they
like doing them and because they like
doing them they do them enough so that
it works for them and the brain likes
doing it so the brain brain you know
enjoys that kind of activity and learns
uh one other thing i should mention when
it comes to polyglots and people who
speak many languages
you'll hear the discussion that richard
and i have where we talk about the
importance of talent we think that
that's not a big issue we think that you
develop the skills the more you study
but you can listen to that if i ever get
the technical problems resolved
um
and uh so i think that a person a
so-called hyperglot is someone who's
just very interested in learning
languages learns one then another than
another
but nevertheless
there was a book written
by called babble no more about the
so-called hyperglots
and
partly as a result of that i think
a global television in toronto is going
to do a television program one hour
television program on the subject of
hyper glides
so i don't know what all is going into
the program it is my understanding
that
richard
uh
is involved in some way
uh and that a number of international
polyglots are involved in this story
and that the global tv has scoured the
internet to find some canadian hyper
gloss and lo and behold towards the
bottom of the barrel they found me so i
am being flown to toronto
uh to participate in this panel
discussion which will probably redu be
reduced to
uh you know a small portion of this of
this program is quite inconvenient for
me because it comes during the easter
weekend and it comes in the middle of a
old timer's hockey tournament so i have
to fly out of here friday noon
and i return saturday afternoon
and toronto is not that close to
vancouver it's about a four and a half
hour flight
but
i think it's very interesting that
they're doing the program and i hope
that it stimulates more interest in
language learning
uh you know amongst the people who'll be
watching the program so there you have
it i apologize for the technical failure
of our first discussion with uh with
richard my discussion with richard i
hope that i'll be able to
recover salvage that interview tomorrow
when i speak to people like alex and
mark who are more technically competent
than i am thank you for listening bye
for now